So, uh, what do you got on the case so far?
Well, the disappearances have been increasing steadily
every month.
And all of them were people from right here in town.
So you think perhaps...
That we got a serial killer on our hands?
Shhhh!!!!
You might be right.
Hopefully it's just a kidnapper.
Don't forget, the bodies haven't even turned
up yet.
There isn't exactly a great way to hide 22
rotting corpses.
Especially in this town.
Is everything OK gentleman?
Yeah. How's your salad?
Um, it's good, it's good.
Thank you.
How's your, uh, chicken fricassee?
To be honest...
I don't really care for it at all.
It's kinda dry and... I don't know.
Something just tastes *off* about it.
I'm sorry man. You, uh, you want to try a
bite of my salad?
Nah, that's alright. I think my whole appetite's been killed.
So do we have any leads at all so far?
Yeah, there's this one guy...
Hey, did I show you my new tattoo?
No. I don't think so.
Check it out.
Nice! I like the design.
Yeah.
Are you alright?
I think I'm gonna be sick.
Aughhh!!!!!
Oh my God!
*gasps*
Jesus!
Aughh!!
Is he OK?
Hey!
Hey, need some help over here!
*ambulance siren*
*pig squeals*
Here you go. We have your salad.
Thank you!
You're Welcome.
And your chicken fricassee.
Enjoy.
Thank you.
*french dinner music*